spinal care of nevada the sponsors of
today's segment focuses on modern
low-force chiropractic and they are here
to tell us about some of those long-term
solutions and joining us today is dr
tuck kusmic dr tut thank you for being
here thank you for having me so before
we get into our demo here tell me a
little bit about your chiropractic
office and what you guys practice over
there
yeah so we practice a modern technique
and it doesn't involve as much popping
or cracking and if you are looking for
that type of adjustment i'm probably not
the right doctor
we have many patients who suffer from
migraines headaches neck pain back pain
and knee pain that is so severe they
can't contemplate just where they would
be today if there wasn't an alternative
method so we use this thing called an
arthur stem okay to apply a specific and
gentle adjustment to the spine so that
they can get the relief they desperately
seek and you hear those stories of
people having to go back to the
chiropractic you know offices all the
time and having to return is that
something that's common for you guys or
is it kind of a one and done type of
thing what's the process like so one of
the keys to our success is that we do a
very thorough two day work up day one
they're going to get a detailed history
and an examination complete with digital
x-rays now these are the top films in
our field today and really more people
ought to take them
they'll show us exactly where the
problem is and how we can correct it day
two the patient will come back in will
have had time to review the images and
then if i can't help them i'll send them
to another doctor but if i can help them
i'm gonna spell everything out for them
how much time how much cost any out of
network benefits their insurance gives
them
because the last thing a patient should
have to do is make an important health
decision without the complete picture so
let's show everyone kind of your process
show me how this tool works right here
all right i'll demonstrate on my friend
here who is totally not a former patient
so
the brain sits here in the skull sends
signals down the spinal cord and exits
out through the nerves so if a bone goes
out of place here pinching the nerve
that's going to lead to things like
headaches migraines so by adjusting here
a specific
and gentle adjustment we're able to
reduce symptoms and improve function as
well same thing here you got that hump
in your back makes us look older it also
affects lung function so
by correcting that we also get better
breathing better movement in general
same thing with low back pain
leg pain
and you know my mom actually has a slip
disc in her back and she's never found a
solution for it so is that something
that you guys can work on too as well
people who have the slip discs
yeah so we like i said we do a
comprehensive uh work up for everyone
that comes into the office if their disc
is so bad that they can't feel the lower
half of their leg or they're losing
bladder control we'll send them out
that's something we can't fix but if
they're back the disc is so bad that
it's causing pain and down running down
the leg that's something that we can
certainly take pressure off the disc and
off the nerve wow well dr chuck thank
you so much for showing us and really
putting into perspective what you guys
do and you have a special offer for our
viewers right yes so we are offering for
the first 20 callers um the first two
day work up normally that's hundreds of
dollars that includes history exam and
x-rays uh it's only going to be 37
that's what we're going to offer
for patients to take care of their lives
okay well dr tuck thank you for breaking
all that down and once again we'll have
all that information on your screen
thank you to spinal care of nevada for
sponsoring this segment give dr tuck a
call at 702 566 hope that's 4673 or you
can visit
spinalcareofnevada.com and don't forget
about their special offer the first 20
callers can go in and see dr tuck for a
two day work up which includes history
exam and digital x-rays for just 37 that
is normally 180 so a great deal we will
be right back